[Music]
and fighter dine is submitted by Marie
from New York
mighty condo a lone jogger killed a
mountain lion in self-defense with his
bare hand
Oh a man jogging man he was just I heard
that the thing came from his back house
on his back and somehow he was able to
turn around and children so is he like
college how would you want to bet this
cool new jiu-jitsu do you know every
year there's always some kind of
mountain lion attacking our mountains up
here
well they said in the past century
there's been less than ten deaths that's
but attack attacks yeah yeah I mean they
said death I don't know about attacks
but yes exactly what Bart said this man
was attacked from behind so crazy and so
he said that he was able to supplicate
him to death how much like a little a
little teen tiger we're not gonna
tighten the [ __ ] neck is like this
big Kris mouth is have no idea they
didn't specify exactly six fingers no
yeah like that you pinched it close they
said it was a younger younger that's
what I'm thinking
I probably covered its ears I freaked
out no you killed it you put them in the
ice like this what if he just like stood
on his neck with his knee you do MMA
[ __ ] I don't know when I see a wild
animal that's a different story
yeah because a mountain lion doesn't
have like a neck and head like it's
shaped like us so if you do a cookie
like a [ __ ] we're naked or whatever I
feel like it will just slip right
through the idea of doing a rear naked
choke on a [ __ ] mountain lions great
I do it on my dog the armbar like doing
a paw paw bar yeah you know I like furry
animals so much I feel like if I saw a
dude rear naked choke a mountain lion
I'll report animal abuse if he had been
attacked you even would do that you
think you got bleeding with like
scratches I might not do got a die huh
don't be hurting animals
yeah so even if it's like say a [ __ ]
what's it called like Tyson sighs dog
comes in after you you're just gonna be
like I deserve it
you should close your eyes except your
feet now I'm a ground by pilots the
bucket Neiman's stomach all animals are
slippery as [ __ ] too because all that
fern [ __ ] I try to dodge Jitsu all the
time and if you wear this sweater and
you do that with them it's like two
slipping and you can't slip you're
trying to hold the dog and put it on his
back if it doesn't want to I should put
you just gotta get the other legs and
pull them that way and Endel fall to the
side yeah that would know [ __ ] they
don't know [ __ ]
that was fun you did you see her she's
so [ __ ] stiff she won't let you I get
her ass well yeah it was a young
mountain where they call a juvenile we
see a teen I said it juvenile so they're
saying that they don't know exactly how
he did it but that he did suffocate him
to death with his bare hand so I have no
was it here in LA Colorado
see I like nature but not when it
attacks me when the nature attacks would
be a sick name of Michelle taxi that
sounds like his name of a show if it's
not already yeah so he was able to so he
did suffer like a lot of injuries but
they weren't life dress life-threatening
he was able to get himself to the local
hospital he was bitten on the face and
the wrist and so when he got to the
hospital they they asked him like what
happen to you he was like oh man's not
lying just text me he's dead though you
go get his body and so yeah they found
him how big is his mountain lion cuz if
he killed the [ __ ] mountain lion I
was this big
i'ma be highly disappointed I know like
a little cub they did say it possibly
wait at least 80 pounds oh that's a big
[ __ ] Butler I'm sorry that's huge
they get pretty big you know we have
them like right in our backyard right
here - and then I watch footage online
of hiker vloggers and then they tie
cameras to different trees and stuff
that are motion detected and then right
here like right in our hills in one
night it'll be like a bear like a family
of a bear and then like a cub and [ __ ]
and then after that a mountain lion and
then like
like a homeless guy peeing in Griffith
Park you know and then [ __ ] homeless
guy trying to suck his own dick
yeah just like it's like it's like right
yeah it's like a flock ton of animals
and the crazy part is like there'll be
people that are just hiked in the same
trail yeah yeah I didn't you'll just put
this footage together and it's [ __ ]
nuts like pictures oh this guy just like
the time-lapse is super fast you try
suck his own dick that he just goes up
set I like to stand by this one tree and
try to supply again a lot of parts
service people they said that lions are
elusive animals and so they tend to
avoid humans for the most part but if
you are if if you are ever confronted by
a mountain lion never run because
running will stimulate the Lions
instinct chasing it face that
[ __ ] and punch them in the face
you have to like make yourself big and
if you're wearing a jacket to open your
deck you go like this and you have to
make yourself seem like you're more of a
threat to the Lions so turn around and
open up your organs you gotta do the
thrillers move you know to Michael
Jackson that's a scary [ __ ] you can come
up with just like snap dancing in a
parking garage there's like really
[ __ ] angry scary [ __ ] you know I'm
gonna get you buddy
yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] that all those
people when they come to LA they they
hike to Runyon Canyon yeah running
there's a bunch of mountain lions there
I think I want to see their homes where
they sleep yeah
oh they're also with the million dollar
seed by the way [ __ ] ridiculous the
bear caves in now hey I know I'm gonna
try like a wild game like bear meat and
stuff like that what I'm so curious
about what it tasted John Rogan makes it
seem like it tastes like the best thing
in the world he's talking about even the
backstrap of a mountain lion tastes
delish Joe Rogan has successfully like
told me four hundred times about his
eating help me and now I need to try
opening yeah it's so annoying I'm like
[ __ ] I didn't
I'll be before my even advertised it to
me burger is sacramental Sacramento
burger shops without all kinds of meat
you could try it's not boring like out
here Joe Rogan doesn't look like
somebody that I want to take advice
about what tastes good yeah mouth
naturally tastes of metal yeah I feel
like he could eat a cigarette and you
say it tastes amazing yeah he's got
enough salt on his tongue no matter what
no matter what meat he's eating and like
it's got that it tastes good to him yeah
I just I don't know if I like trust his
opinion you know but he added some guy
who was like he's like an outdoorsman or
some [ __ ] yeah and he was talking about
not all bear meat tastes great it highly
depends on what season you catch them in
because a lot of the times these Bears
they'll eat like rotten salmon rotten
whatever just were the nutrients and
you'll taste that into meat its putrid
they said like this the bear meat tastes
putrid but like during the springtime or
whatever wonder berries come in they'll
eat a lot of no forage for berries and a
lot of these herbs yeah and then they'll
their meat actually tastes like
blueberry yeah I mean that's called
that's the same thing for cows to it's
called finishing or like you want to
have a high [ __ ] farmer you want to
have a high carb low carbohydrate diet
so then it's sweet or the meter your
farmers like corn and stuff like that
because everyone goes oh grass-fed it's
so good so it's not good I want to
produce a photo shoot where I direct it
for you and I want to put you in costume
in scenarios of things that you want to
do with your life so I want you farmer
fishermen yes sugar cane
yeah all right mud hug yeah gambling
yeah every profession you was saying I
already pictured in the calendar dude I
got you over owner not a Megamall
calendar but a Megamall calendar thank
you very let me know when you want me to
hook you up I got a point I think though
your dream and I will speak for you is
to star as the Jamaal Ian King in a
Bollywood film I think that would be
absolutely incredible he was advised he
doesn't want a movie he wants the like a
lot of people and then you record that
like a circus I was showing him this
Bollywood video yesterday that's [ __ ]
great and picturing him as the lead of
it makes me [ __ ] former GOP in a
Bollywood but not as a jamali like you
wants to be the guy with the weird hair
want to be the indian man you don't know
your friend do know I wanna be cool Iman
no I didn't know in a Bollywood video
that's it yeah I was dead wrong I want
to be yeah I want to be that Ghulam a
guy Indian Indian thriller I love that
guy fight like 40 guys yeah can you beat
all of us yeah in the weirdest moves
like remember the [ __ ] Turkish action
movie where all he's doing is kicking
people oh yeah that's the best Hollywood
movies are the best dude there's so good
man there's this scene that I love from
this one thing left so they literally
did this scene where this guy was being
chased by a dog right and they're trying
to do a cutscene of the dog jumping over
something but you could tell they didn't
had trained dogs so you literally see
the hands of the man and he chucked the
dog in the doctor's going sideways to be
they just got the feed like this that's
just old Hollywood [ __ ] so I used to do
manage to do all kind of [ __ ] like you
know like what a dog jumps clearly you
could tell it's intentional this dog was
just you know in westerns when like they
shoot a horse I'm pretty sure all those
guys you should just [ __ ] shoot the
horse in the movie sometimes when I
watch indonesian films right and i see
like the scene where a guy gets
roundhouse in the face i'm like they
can't afford stun and that's an actual
roundhouse to the face and at the end is
just an obituary yeah they used to [ __ ]
each other rough dude yeah yeah oh yeah
when you watch Jackie Chan [ __ ] that's
what's cool about it is you know like it
rumble in the Bronx who's [ __ ] yeah he
didn't even have those booty call it
those [ __ ] inflatable things that you
fall on it was just to jump you know he
would get cardboard you would get
cardboard boxes and like put them up
together
yeah which sucks by the way that sucks
tool and by the way he was [ __ ] 40
years old when that movie came out he's
a madman
hundred right now Calculon Jackie Jin is
to me and I know this will be
controversial but to me he's the most
entertaining like of all the martial
arts stars ever I think he's also the
most asexual badass I've ever met
oh for sure well he just never want sex
ever he's known like bang hello chicks
but just his persona it's not very sexy
yeah I cried another sex icon persona
anybody's extremely badass he's like the
most undesirable alpha male I've ever
seen do Rumble the Bundys cyber yoga
Rumble abrazo that one asian chick was
[ __ ] hot in their show yo right no it
was some other girl oh the girl with the
little brother and the wheelchair oh
brother dude those a funny scene when he
hid the diamonds in the seats and the
guy threw him out the wheelchair - any
fall yeah that's what I'm saying he took
what Bruce Lee did and he like made it
even funnier and he but he also kept the
same fighting style like the real
fighting [ __ ] like I just he's the man
then Duncan masturbated
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]